cette ménagerie et ce cirque installé
depuis peu sur le terrain d'une zone
commerciale au sud de sens ne plaisent
pas à tout le monde
ce défenseur de la cause animale nous a
contactés pour dénoncer cette situation
on voit qu'il ya des fauves notamment
des tigres et des lions qui sont qui
sont dans des cages créé petty et en
mois de janvier qui sont dehors donc ça
ça pose problème
les animaux sauvages n'ont rien à faire
dans un cirque en fait surtout dans des
cercles mobiles qui sont entraînés tous
les to les semaines d'un point a à un
point b
l'installation du cirque serait aussi
illégal jointe par téléphone
l'enseigne propriétaire du terrain nous
affirme qu'un constat d'huissier a été
dressé et qu'une procédure d'expulsion
et tendre mais pour le directeur du
cirque c'est un mauvais procès il nous
montre le contrat signé avec lens n y ai
dit respecter la loi
c'est vrai qu'on est arrivé deux ou
trois jours d'avancé pour installer donc
ça peut-être pas plu à auchan conseil
arrivée d' avance mais on ne peut pas
installer un cirque eux en matinée c'est
impossible
avec plus de 40 animaux serge muller dit
ne rien avoir à cacher et tiennent à
nous montrer ses animaux la main
chameaux dromadaires et autres chevaux
sont ici bien traité il ya peut-être des
associations qui disent qu'ils sont pas
bien dans les cirques
mais nous nos animaux donc ils sont
suivis par des vétérinaires donc on a
des certificats de capacité pour lui
détenir dans deux animaux sont suivies
malgré la polémique le public semble
répondre présente les représentations du
week-end dernier se sont jouées à
guichet fermé et d'autres sont encore
prévus jusqu'en fin de semaine